okay hello everyone my name is Nicolas I
work at front of Institute for solar
energy and I want to tell you what we do
with satellite images this is me and a
colleague standing next to our satellite
dish with this dish we receive satellite
images from a geostationary satellite
this is what a satellite image looks
like we receive oh yeah I hope you can
see it every receive bottom that was
every 15 minutes all the time in real
time and with this image we compute
first we compute something called in a
pitot it's hard to see but it's
basically what earth would look like if
there were no clouds with this thing we
can then compute something called a
cloud index that basically tells you how
much clouds are there in a given
location if it's bright there's a cloud
if it's dark there's no cloud next we
use something called a clear sky model a
clear sky model tells you for a given
location and time what the solar
irradiance at that location in time
would be if there were no clouds solar
irradiance is measured in watts per
square meter in this clear sky model
combined with the cloud enix
gives us a time series of what the solar
irradiance was at the location this
method is cool what we can do is we can
take actual solar irradiance
measurements from ground sensors and
then we can fit our model parameters so
that our satellite method fits the
ground measurements but this method only
tells me what the irradiance is now or
what it was in the past I also want to
know what it's in the future so what we
do is we take those cloud indices and we
compute something called a cloud motion
vector basically that's an optical flow
it tells me how the clouds moved in the
past
and if I assume that the cloud movement
will stay the same I can actually do use
that to predict how the cloud indices
will look like in the future and with a
lot the next forecasts I can then create
a solar irradiance forecast
[Music]
next let's assume you have a PV power
plant if I know enough about your PV
power plant I can put in irradiance data
and create something clean create
simulated PV power like basically I
simulate your power plant and again what
I can do is if I have measurements power
measurements from your plant I can
fine-tune the plant simulation
parameters so that my simulated PV power
fits your power measurements and once I
have the optimized simulation I can put
in my irradiance forecast and create a
PV power forecast and with that I
conclude what we do with satellite
images thanks
[Applause]